we're here to pick up Mina fall hopper
2016 retail and e-commerce 30 under 30
honoree she has a go at yeah but we're
gonna surprise her with the mentoring
session with one of the top retail
experts out there today welcome to a day
[Music]
here a lot of the samples that we have
been working on and are working on hello
stuff is technical as in bring the boats
wet weekend can run marathons in and he
could wear it anywhere into anything the
properties of the clothing are really
important so we wanted to be versatile
and breathable we also want it to be
long-lasting we think that that really
simplifies and that helps people so like
pare down their wardrobes and really
focus on what's important to consumers
mindset is sort of just starting to
shift and we want to be on the forefront
of that we think there's a big big big
brand to be built here ok well let's
head downstairs
so what would you say is like the
biggest thing on your plate right now
that you're trying to develop at your
business
Darren except we've grown revenue is a
ton and as a result we've grown kinda
the team as well the store I've always
had a very strong culture although our
team members and joined us because they
were really passionate about what we do
words yes you're growing you want to
make sure that you you're able to like
dedicate enough time and mentorship and
whatnot to each and every one of their
employees in order to help them like be
their best selves as he's killing it's a
challenge to kind of ensure that
everyone is actually referring how it's
dads
what's up so we're actually gonna meet
someone today who will be able to better
answer some of the questions you have
about your business so is gonna get out
of the guilt you guys have grown so fast
how do you maintain sort of culture as
you execute intensively you want to
think through how you hire people I'm
gonna make sure the new people embody
aspects of your culture try to have a
culture where the learning could come
from anywhere our goal is to create
staples you bring out pieces on a
regular basis but then we want a lot of
them to stay on the shelf and how does
that play into PR you need to be feeding
them new angles and new stories and you
have things to pitch it used to always
be product it used to be very driven by
part I can write easy and now it's a
little more like we need to be more
creative around the stories we want to
tell I nature I'm a pretty social person
but if you find yourself with the
tendency of you know just hunkering down
and focus maybe give yourself a little
quarterly calendar reminder if they're a
few investors who you've either met
along the way or you'd like to meet who
you think would be relevant encourage
that relationship in an organic way I
think also if you get invited to any
types of venture capital events or
mixers or conferences go I would just
encourage you to continue to get out
there as much as possible to promote the
brand with the products and have fun
with it looks like you're having so much
fun it's hard it is a roller coaster but
you're doing great and look how far
you've come in such a short period of
time all right
well keep me posted thank you that's
hard to go quite the surprise what kind
of things did you guys talk about I
think it's time they're like you know I
start going going out a little and like
be really the voice of the brand's and
speak more at conferences and do one
thing so it was great it's great huh a
moment or conversation can like shift
thinking and perspective a little it's
great well thanks so much for joining us
today and I'm so glad you enjoy speaking
without saying thank you for for the
street
[Music]